so you realize this won't stop
there are millions of arrests made every
year the odds that a dozen or so will
end up horribly
a hundred percent all it takes is one
video to set it off
and of course the media that inflames it
the videos are shocking
what unites them awful visuals what
makes them different
the stories behind them the death of
george floyd and tony tempa
share common traits but they're
different races
which changes how it's covered should it
the stats back up what i said after the
floyd killing what you're seeing is
procedural malfeasance
bad training unbending minds and now
it's countered with an equally unbending
unlistening rage now steering a country
toward ruin
and all it takes is another video is
there something the media can do to save
us
yeah they can stop pushing inflammatory
uninformed opinions
here's my prescription the media should
get a room
and read the stats of police
interactions and note every single
mistake shown in these videos
all races included there they might find
that the culprits are actually bad
tactics
and training the race part fades when
you see how many whites are killed
and that non-white police are more
likely to shoot non-white suspects
it's time to take the foot off the race
pedal and place it on
training and tactics so real reforms can
be made
so the cities can stop burning and we
can stop killing each other
in the wake of the floyd turmoil chicago
saw 18 murders
in 24 hours the most violent day
in that city's 60 years who do you think
the victims were
so media appears why don't we all head
to a holiday in express conference room
and face the facts literally i'll even
spring for the room
so um dana the media has absolutely no
idea
how to police itself when it comes to
this story yet they demand
that the they they believe they can
police the police
this really frightens me
so first of all i want to know if you're
going to have pastries in the room at
the holiday inn express because if so we
will make sure we are there
um
he does he loves the cookies um i i do
think
that the we we know that
the media does follow stories like this
and especially if there's fire right um
but i also think that there's another
angle here and that is the social media
angle
um and and that is also i think fueling
things that maybe even the traditional
media doesn't
understand or see that they're late to
it and i think
that was one of the things you heard
from the protesters especially they're
saying that we've been talking about
this for years and it took a video for
you to
to believe us now on the good news side
of things and the things that you
mention in terms of
training and tactics in the legislation
that senator tim scott has been working
on and i think there's some bipartisan
support on it
they have things like dealing with
accountability
training transparency de-escalation
issues
no knock warrants issues those types of
concrete things so that perhaps
if we all focus on get helping this
legislation get across the finish line
we would have done
a good service for the country
yeah one it seems like whenever i turn
on cnn which is rarely
they're trying to incite a race war it
seems like this is something that is
their profit
their profit center and it's very
disturbing
well i i hope there's no race war coming
i think that
you know what i i just want to respond
to what you were saying because i found
it interesting greg
to my mind i think that what we have is
you know and i've said this to you
before i think the police unions a lot
of those contracts
that the politicians sign on to are
really
the root cause here because they protect
bad
police officers and i don't think that's
in anybody's interest
i think we should not have a situation
where the guy leading on floyd's neck
had you know repeated complaints and
he's back on not only back on the force
he's back on the street
we've heard this from the minneapolis
police chief etc but i also think when
you speak about
malfeasance i think it's important to
highlight malfeasance and the media
should do it because i think people
who've not had
voice people who've been ignored in
terms of
you know pre-video complaints about
abusive police behavior
if they see that in fact the media
reflects
their reality they feel better they feel
like you know what society
is responding the power structure will
respond
and that's how you get changed that's
how you get reform
the best of media is when media as they
say
you know uh afflicts the comfortable and
comforts the afflicted
so i think in this case yeah razor
ruckus let people see what's going on
and let's have
some reform all right um i agree with
the reform
but digging if if we rely on these
videos without context of the stats
this will never end if we only choose
specific
uh incidents and overlook others like
the tony tempest of the world
then you're going to get a distorted
view of a reality
right the tony tempest incident raises
what i was talking about earlier
is how well-equipped police officers are
to deal with the mentally ill and just
even from personal experience it's
it can be really horrific but i want to
single out another bastion of liberalism
not
cnn but the technology world because
if you're going to change black lives
in the united states you've got to
basically
increase prosperity more job security
more wealth people
people who are not financially
vulnerable in an economic downturn
unemployment rate tripled from february
to may and it was actually for black
americans
going up so i'm going to call out apple
and tim cook
because he's always very quick to quote
dr martin luther king
jr in response to say george floyd's
death
but here's where apple's stats were in
just a couple years ago in 2018.
a percentage of america 13 of the us
population
is black u.s apple employs overall
nine percent in just technology jobs
six percent leadership three percent
look at google they want to tell you
what to do
how about going into high schools and
hiring
young black people and training them in
areas where there aren't opportunities
at google less than four percent of the
workforce
are black americans leadership under
three percent
that's disgraceful stop talking start
walking
all right jesse last word can the media
change itself can it police itself
greg is an expert in human behavior and
group psychology and as a
seasoned veteran for political
commentary
and media analysis i would say that
people just can't be persuaded with
facts and logic and statistics
this country is run by feelings i mean
you can look at the russia thing people
still think trump's a
russian spy even after three years of
us pointing it out that it's false they
still believe it so you're not going to
change people's minds with all your
beautiful logic gut-felled
it's got to be done through feelings and
if a majority of the country feel
like this is a racist country and
there's racist police
brutalizing black america well then
those feelings become a reality
so unfortunately you're just gonna have
to change people's
perceptions and feelings because then we
can figure out the facts later because
they're not listening to the facts
all right then well that's a dark way to
end this segment jesse